stupid Wade and everyone else said
enormous that my associate producers buy
my recording team how many people are in
that room he explained earlier I'm
fighting by Corona rules a good place to
play for turell's Corona rules it's like
what's that family from Billy Madison
Oh Doyle Doyle rules rules rules and
then they all die it's hilarious I
didn't know the computer live in that
department Oh everyone lies when they
have the chance Oh am i lying right now
call me up call me how about call me I
feel like I've literally can't I can
observe for myself oh yeah you are he's
a liar I like the way you guys like liar
[Music]
uh he'll do it Mars emphasized chainsaw
I just heard in the background no it's
my boom arm just needs a little Lube
[Music]
yeah full can of wd-40 on that [ __ ] it
is really squeaky I noticed before is it
my turn that's literally your boom are
ya man dude I've been youtube along like
a month this thing's been following me
around forever
everytime like you uh switch up your
office or something you just throw
everything out and start over I guess I
don't know dude I'm the opposite of
looks um when it comes to computers this
boom arm I can't afford to replace yeah
absolutely course I feel like moving my
tower over moves they could just have it
but my boobs for that you could just
shut up yeah you do yeah I didn't get
him mark that wait I'm gonna let you
give it to mark now DBC command
battle huh yeah see this is what you get
wait skip again mark daddy oh yeah you
know this guy I did that on purpose yeah
yeah take you to ticket Wade aha yeah
what I don't like what's happening here
and you all need to stop doing that
please oh well but hey
Hey
I thought we were giving it to each
other I thought we were doing guys
you're gonna make me do something I'm
gonna regret don't know don't know
Oh ChatterBait are your only fans are
you oh you're just changing the cards I
don't need to I didn't learn - you know
what mark what I'm gonna help you out
bye buddy
I don't like your version of help I
don't know why I don't wanna I know why
I don't want and I don't want it no I
oh wow what the [ __ ] there you go
watching wave win repeatedly da thank
you Bob
thank you can be nice it's not weird no
it's not I'd like it wise he feels good
no feels good that's some good stuff in
like adult as we want it's not the check
the charity stream you know Bob on the
charity stream the first thing happens I
was like all right we're gonna try keep
this little PG cuz there's a bunch of
kids watching the marks like I'm gonna
[ __ ] my pants that's not even what I
first opened up with you know we just
got filming done filming a jackoff
competition in my wrist a little bit
this economy you fill the jackoff
competition yeah that's what I did oh
that's so good we were we were five feet
away from each other
yeah so it's so you're safe yeah you
were isolated it's like when you filmed
that uh the animal sex gamer you be able
to show you that on camera I never I
never recorded a video of that what were
you doing in my office for - dude do you
need me to explain
[Music]
just to reinforce the ideas reinforce it
yeah you called me after so long
wait check this game I don't think
that's how it went down but I'm ok with
imagining that's out went down after
like two hours I was like pouring sweat
down my brow just wait I gotta show you
something amazing that's exactly what
happened it's not far off
no it's not thank you wow what a nice
game what a nice game alright that's
that's not how this usually goes hey I
got a medal win all rounds and I match
15 time oh you're 21 now I never thought
this day would come
good job you can't drink you know you're
the right level yay well no I still
probably couldn't employ you can't
that's true I forgot
let me see what you got wait let me see
what you got mm-hmm
don't you want my cards no I don't want
your cards so listen mark before you
make your decision let me sell you on
this my head is good and you want to see
what's in it I'm sold
I know I'm sold way no I'm buying on you
please yes
I'll Dusty's lying sack of [ __ ] Leslie
is a liar liar pants on fire
where's my green it's right there in my
hand guys ha ha ha ha stupid idiots I
got you huh they asked me where my green
was is right there in my hand there's
such idiots bottom yes garlotte's I'm
not doing that here we go now I'll look
Bob you sold this hand but those aren't
money that's not the ones that are
selling you on though
and you fool oh you fool this sucks the
current climate this was a monster of a
hand it needs the right it just needs a
little love you see it a little bit get
warmed up right don't judge it right
don't don't let it don't tell it your
darkest secrets because it'll I'll
betray you but just what are you gonna
do huh what are you gonna do you can't
do anything I'm looking I'm go I better
play you can do nothing to me
no you are off in time here we go you
hadn't said anything I was considering
Martin but then you spoke what's this I
the hot seat again we'll see what fate
smiles upon thee how did you know he was
gonna do that I don't Big Al and I are
on the opposite page if I'm thinking red
he's playing blue
what happened at all you're right you
right right this is gonna be a good game
I have a feeling me around this is gonna
be a good game Bob the skin feeling it's
gonna be what do you want Bob what do
you want what do you want yellow is cool
oh all right I like sorry Bob
[Laughter]
good game guys I feel good about okay
that's not that's not very nice
Wow I have so many sevens guys you need
sevens I got extra sevens just this red
really kind of the back of all of your
cards right I'm playing one of those
play that Muno logo this will go with
this and all right let's go this way and
I'm gonna stick to it interesting My
Luck is it's gonna turn around just okay
it's a mechanic called jumping in and
you'll never play you know you'll never
play you'll never play let's do it to
avoid to be Diddy is that Daddy you're
trying to give him daddy but he gave it
back to me see now see ya
it's good mr. ie oh hey blue guess I'll
play this yeah I have a question about
the red choice as well a little a little
hit a mystery I yeah yeah oh that's just
a regular to examine don't worry buddy
I'll let you play this time here I have
it too well funny about this there's a
carefully how mark I just love how
throughout these games like it's always
towards the end we all just deflate it's
just so depressed other things with your
life no God you know and it's a lot of
telling who's going on
oh no oh no get-get a mark I will get
them it's still we still have a chance
oh sure I just feel it's gonna be it
comes that green zero you're gonna give
daddy what do you want oh it's kind of a
zero yeah that's a that's the right
shape and everything what's the one else
you like about that is that not right
that's fine it's gonna be a good I have
a feeling in my bones of bones
you gotta stay and you gotta stop saying
the over feeling because I hear the
start to that Black Eyed Peas song every
time you do I got a feeling that's this
and it's going the opposite of good blue
mark you like oh yeah literally just the
worst green what are you so upset about
you don't have to draw cards way just
play green blue green Wow
that's being just silly good the says
the van he was so complaining about blue
for so long well I could could you could
have mark what color you want at this
point it doesn't matter deal not that
one well I I know that one hmm
interesting interesting
very interesting green now I'll [ __ ] you
oh not a good game farther off I had no
hope for almost the entire time I should
have listened to you you were right you
had a feeling and it was now you feel
about this one now be how you feel about
this yeah wait give us your reading oh
oh oh disciple you know what I'll tell
him how he feels
oh you feel spicy about this one this
could be a happen happen happen in route
how do you feel bad I felt pretty good I
don't feel as good did you know I did I
did at La saloon for come on wait it's
gonna be a good round you feel good I
looked at your cards you feel really
excited about your I feel that's that
stings
I got a state well never mind that's a
plus two alright no god it looks bad
it looks bad it's not it's gonna be fine
it's gonna be fun don't stress man don't
worry about it it's gonna be so fine
Wayne good good well that's that's fine
that's fine
look I'm just helping actually that did
help me out a lot cuz I got to give it
to old Al they're right in the back door
if you know what I mean this economy
what okay
oh man that gets like Alice sort of
problem with me hmm
do it to a mark oh you know I will go
after her to the cards baby my heart of
the cards
heart of the heart of the cards heard of
the curves
[Laughter]
[Applause]
mark what have you done apparently the
second someone says Kali my cycles
around I didn't know that was the cycle
twice I know I'm sorry that started off
as a bit but then I turn into race cars
driving past in my head like good stuff
beautiful so I feel great about this
game thank you buddy I felt good about
this game I don't like this game anymore
I just had to have a little bit of whip
in before I could whip it no this game
is dumb and I hate it like how I'm the
only one who's not a hundred percent
polarized after the finish of every
single round listen this game is taxing
wait I jumped in well here it is anyway
that doesn't seem very nice update on
your turn I was gonna jumped in anyway
oh you silly [ __ ] here's two fives you
did oh you [ __ ] just if we could wow
I don't think helmet I think you oh my
god my hand is Christmas Oh apparently
this is so like you know I wouldn't have
won that's the word you're hunting for
desperately mark typical
oh really well your days not today
saying oh people that's what I say
pickle do tickle dicta cool old pickles
that's what I'm
[Music]
tickle-tickle in mind
come on man listen look I'm getting
demonetised Wade can you just tone down
the dick yeah be careful what you wish
for a very specific date or wording I'm
a monkey's paw of sorts yeah go for a
free ride baby
so consistent and predictable
well that's an interesting choice it's
gonna pan out for me oh thank you Bob
bake it yellow you'll have those three
cards again mm-hmm I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna play so difficult working
together on this Mary yeah we're gonna I
kind of zoned out for the last 20
minutes just freed up all the sudden so
I'm awake here we go
that's it my back that was weird
no never thought I'd see him again Oh
Laureen okay okay okay okay
oh really wait oh really
yeah oh really that's what you don't get
that's not what you get wait a minute
we're supposed to be much more severe
come on Al yeah I'll give it to him yeah
way back to bridge pay but that's not
how that works
Wow no I think that was worth the
information good good good good
[Applause]
that's one bubble color do you need read
me daddy I cannot I give you blue
never mind I say we go places oh dear
real dumb I was real done guys we're
green now oh [ __ ] you well hey whoa whoa
whoa
how many what was your trying to hit
mark damn dude I hit the whoa every days
every day I'm just whoa
like I heard back in the race boys all
right my turn time to tear up town with
a six oh you silly fool I'll give you
half of that and we'll double it to make
it pal I'm gonna do that you're gonna
get right back you're gonna get good but
now I know I know what you have I'm
assuming in a game called uno having
lots of ones is a positive so I feel
like I'm winning
yeah you just got rid of the ones you
silly fool oh that's from dodgeball
though you're not a pirate Who am I
gonna share this booty with that he's
like God why yellow why worry about no
you're right thank you that was
beautiful
thank you Oh tricks on you it's a stupid
card he's got blue they call my dick the
punishment I don't like that mmm that's
Oh God so much bad stuff you like it now
no no no oh they call marks The Punisher
- what did I do
I just put a 5y he read so I'm Fred Chad
this time I know what I said
No
Oh one day I was gonna run for public
office and everything I've said in the
last 10 years is gonna come back all
right office I'm gonna be President in
10 years just you watch that was a fake
story Wade where you were given the
opportunity to do the job of a teacher
whom you insulted and successful it was
a fake story that's not gonna happen
you dare to be I will teach not dare you
I was mockingly telling a fake story I
was making up oh my god
you all suck no thank you
you know what everything works out I'm
gonna give you a gift
never mind all right this is really you
know what mark I'm gonna give you a gift
okay punishing Wade that's not feel like
Wade really got punished
yeah Wade skin absolutely right now
getting cream pod was it green get it
right those face or I didn't come clean
about something I actually don't even
know what that is
Horace's no I know what face orifices I
don't know what what I said is what are
you saying you're sure you don't know
what cream pie is you don't know dude I
don't believe anything you're saying
right now
I honestly as a sex thing I don't
actually know it I don't know what it
means you're I only know that in the
context I didn't see that you drew it
okay on my face cream in my pie am i
right guys like that wolf that's on me
which part is pot is it your face your
butthole or your peepee uh-huh dude I
don't like this train of question yeah
this is no good Wade you were 30 years
old Wade I'm using my mark Google right
now I'm trying
no no you're 30 years old go to google
card you don't have any of those nuts
now this works I had one I had one left
now you didn't know I would have had
some and I definitely didn't have three
what you've got three more Google's know
I'll never got one you've got three that
doesn't sound like a thing I've mark
Sarah Lee likes to tolerate our presence
when he asked to hang out with us boys
it does to contact him socially yeah he
didn't know anybody was like taking a
part is watching wasn't paying attention
whenever he offered it up that's
probably true that's poetry I have no
not made that sound like him but D you
can trust me no because she's smarter
than you as a fact yeah mr. Burgess I
love pie I mean we were all thinking it
the fridge
well okay these are all my cards now
[Music]
okay this feels like bullying wait on
your stream right now pull up Google
Google Image Search just google cream
pie there you see the delicious thing
that we're talking about wave you know
you want some of mine come on Wade all
right I've played all the good cards out
of it already so enjoy that Bob we share
an ice cream Google image searching it
right now why wouldn't you do it you
don't know what it is come on stop come
on
[Music]
me crying Bob you remember the the brawl
where I was telling everyone all day
that I was getting a hint I tattoo
instead of saying the word henna you
mean the best day of my life
[Laughter]
goddamn it why blue how many blues it's
a weird thing to admit but I there's no
way there's no way I can imagine what it
probably means but I don't know for a
fact there you go that's it that's the
one pi equals pp lying don't read don't
read them out loud $20 to search it up
hey turn on media share turn on media
shares a lot worse than what I could
even imagine worse no it's a great thing
what are you talking about delicious
thing what do you mean worse yeah I'm
not gonna do it to you mark I just want
to let you know I could have done it to
you I appreciate it well you might get
your chance I feel like at that point
you would have had to do it to me and I
we yeah we could not good how could I
not how could I not not exactly pretty
not just the right amount yeah damn you
were bald ass did you guys see the post
going around there was like oh I don't
want to socially isolate myself so that
I don't spread the coronavirus but I do
want to be banished from the kingdom
[Laughter]
pretty good that's very noble I like
that I like that it's all a new way owls
victory hangs in the balance and here it
is thank God sweet ones out there
research later tonight ourselves look it
was a cream pie stream that's great I
think that's enough uno for me today I
think I'm good yes
I'm hungry for some reason
[Music]